ils attendent que monseigneur macaire
leur prêtent audiences après une heure
d'attenté devant l'archevêché
les salariés du séminaire collèges font
chou blanc
voilà le message est transmis par un
prêtre qui ne souhaitent pas être filmé
le personnel du collège et du lycée
privé de direction de présidence depuis
la rentrée réclame des explications nous
sommes retrouvés quasiment désoeuvrés
sans aucune présence avec juste une
information que donc que notre chef
d'établissement était donc
mise à pied par mesure conservatoire on
a juste envie d'entendre de façon
transparente tous ceux qui reprochaient
à notre échelle établissements mais
également la crédibilité de ceux qui
pointent du doigt notre chef
d'établissement je crois qu'on a besoin
de cette vérité il s'est quand même
essentiel pour nos pour pouvoir
poursuivre dans les meilleures
conditions ils ont retrouvé une ambiance
sereine et saine de travail pas
d'autorisation de filmer le séminaire
collège mais sachez que ce matin les
quelques rares élèves qui se sont
présentés étaient en permanence dans la
tente que les parents viennent les
récupérer
les absents ont été prévenus hier des
enseignants annoncent que les cours
reprendront demain normalement